We just started and there's so many gifted!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you guys!
Holy moly canoli...
Stromboli...
Zamboni...
That doesn't look quite right.
Thank you guys!
Welcome back, master and mistress!
Hello everybody!
Hello!
I get this too fast!
Actually, I can't even keep up.
This is insanity.
Oh my goodness, thank you guys!
Thank you so much!
Thank you for all the gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Holy cow!
Happy anniversary!
Thank you!
It's weird because it's like...
I mean, obviously I'm not going to celebrate this anniversary every year, right?
Because it's not really my anniversary.
Like, my anniversary is in July.
So...
It's funny to be like...
I get two anniversaries this year!
But this year, only this time we'll celebrate one year back, right?
I'm allowed?
Yippee!
Many anniversaries.
It'll start to lose it's pizzazz.
Probably.
It'll probably lose the pizzazz after some time.
If I did so many, you know?
Anniversary every day.
Returniversary, yeah.
Returniversary yesterday.
And I just wanted to do some karaoke.
Pretty chill.
Maybe.
How do you... Wait, I have to ask.
What is this question, Justin?
What is this?
Am I feeling okay?
Yeah!
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I... I initially had a little bit of a migraine.
But...
I'm okay now.
Actually, actually.
Oh my gosh.
I was like, oh, I think I need like an extra 15 minutes.
Because usually it takes like...
Takes like half hours over the meds to kick in, baby.
And I did.
So we're all good.
Yeah, thank you for all the gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
The notice are gonna be backed up to hell.
But I see, I see.
You stream lab donos, I see you.
Thank you for that, Kasupa.
Karenai hana.
Have you requested that before?
Hold on, I'm gonna go check.
If you did, I didn't write it down.
I wrote it down.
I have a channel called...
Called Songs to Learn.
Songs to Learn.
Congrats on your business insider article.
Oh my gosh, I'm so embarrassed.
I'm so embarrassed.
Yeah, I got an email.
They were like, hi, I'm from Business Insider.
I recently interviewed Yago of Hololive.
Can I interview you too?
I was like...
I was like, wow.
Okay.
It was so... A part of me was like, is this even real?
Am I gonna end up on some site?
Oh yeah, big shot over here.
I was like, this is so crazy.
Yeah, so you can find me.
Famous.
No, rather infamous Vtuber.
Mint Phantom on Business Insider.
You never know what I'm gonna cook up next.
You never know.
I was like, me?
Of all Vtubers?
I felt so shocked.
I feel like there are much better options.
Even for like Indies, you know, but...
Yippee!
Winto's all business.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
That was so funny.
Honorary Vtuber.
I was like, I don't know, when I think of like...
You know, maybe like ShyLily, you know, because she has like the...
She has like a gamer subs everything.
Like, someone like that.
I'm just like twiddling my thumbs over here.
I don't know what the heck I'm doing.
I don't even have...
So I was like, oh, okay, cool.
Yippee!
Well, yeah, so it's funny.
But we're in the big leagues now.
I'm so shy.
I'm so embarrassed.
But Amanda is who interviewed me.
She was very nice.
She was very, very nice.
I also want to say before we start karaoke.
Anything goes.
I'll be honest, I was going to have a setlist and then I got so busy with everything.
Like I started writing things down and I think I wrote two songs down.
And I was like, it's fine.
I'll be able to...
I'll be able to write the other songs down later.
And I did not.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm so ill-prepared.
We're just going by vibes.
We're going by vibes.
My voice is...
My voice has been pretty bad recently.
And the pollen and super ring time is not helping at all.
Oh my gosh, it's actually so, so bad.
So, please...
I'm so sorry in advance.
It might be a little more chill because of that.
Chill and short.
Pollen going kind of crazy this year.
I know.
It is.
We can have borderline marathon karaoke.
Right?
We got to do it again.
No!
She actually said that I showed up in her algorithm.
And she said that she went to Holo Expo.
I think she's going down the rabbit hole so much.
Chill and short just like you.
Chill.
Face interviewer.
Yeah, she was like, I just got back from the big event.
Last month.
And I was like, yeah.
Yeah.
Happy day of birth.
It's not my birthday.
What should we start with, you guys?
Let me get my karaoke stuff up.
If I want to sing some JP songs and they are not...
If they do not have instrumentals, I will...
Wait, is my switch hooked up?
I might have to hook up my switch.
Can you sing He Lives in You from The Lion King 2?
Do I remember?
I think I remember just the chorus.
He lives in you.
He lives in me.
He watches over everything we see.
Game on!
Thank you!
Creativity and sense of humor always make the week easier to get through.
Really?
Swap goals.
Thank you so much for the 50.
Thank you!
Thank you guys for all the gifted memberships.
You guys are going insane.
I just saw how many members were gifted.
How many new members?
Oh my god.
Twinkle Dogs debut song?
Oh yes, I was going to talk about Twinkle Dogs a little bit, right?
Oh my gosh.
Yes, I said that I would talk about my April Fools stream today.
So...
If you didn't...
If you didn't notice...
Maybe you don't have Twitter.
The...
Everybody who debuted were actual wisps.
Who submitted their info to me.
Thank you.
If you don't know what I'm talking about, go watch my...
My April Fools stream.
The debut of Twinkle Dogs.
But...
So I put out a survey and I got thousands of responses.
And I felt so bad.
I could only... I was just like...
How well... You know...
I can only choose like a literal handful.
So...
But everything that I put up...
Actually, I forgot to do something that I was going to ask.
Which was a special talent.
Which, honestly, I was so scuffed and so flustered through the whole thing.
Trying to make everything work that...
I...
I didn't even... Probably wouldn't have even done this special talent.
But it was going to be, you know...
So, I forgot to ask that.
Happy one year!
Thank you!
I will support Rito forever!
Thank you, TokTok!
Thank you!
And...
So yeah...
I pulled all of them randomly, except...
Except Sen.
Who was, I think, number 444.
No, that was Patty.
Patty was 444.
I think.
One of them was 444.
Which I was just like, I have to pick a spooky number.
So...
I picked a spooky number myself.
And then everybody else was pulled randomly.
And...
Originally, so for this song that I made...
Make You Kyunkyun Kyururun Saturday...
Wait.
Make You Kyunkyun Kyururun Friday Night.
See, I'm...
Okay, this is the story.
So, I originally called it...
Make You Kyunkyun Kyururun Saturday Night.
Right?
And then when I...
So each...
Also...
Each time I recorded that...
Was one take.
Each time.
I made it up on the spot for the first one.
And then I just copied...
And then I just followed along...
With myself.
Each time.
And what had happened was...
But...
Well, I say it's a first take.
I was practicing.
And I was like...
Kyunkyun...
Saturday Night.
But I had changed it...
From Saturday...
I originally called it Saturday Night.
And I changed it to Friday Night.
Because it kind of flowed a bit better.
And so then...
I was like...
Saturday...
Whoops!
Friday Night.
And so from there...
I was like...
Wait.
And so I changed the...
Originally, it was just kind of like a thirst song.
Where it was just like...
Oh yeah, baby girl.
You're so...
You know, I'm a dog.
Woof woof.
And so then I changed all the lyrics to be like...
To be like...
Oh no, I can't.
I don't know what day of the week it is.
So...
It was actually an incident.
Like an actual true incident.
That...
That happened.
Finally played the NES games for the first time.
Paid.
So yeah, we can sing Kyun Kyun.
Kyun Kyun.
Here, I'll sing it.
Minto version.
And if you ever want to sing...
Make you Kyun Kyun Kyururun Saturday...
Oh, sorry.
Friday Night.
It's actually a Doba Syndrome song.
Called...
Is it this one?
Yeah.
Called Sum...
Wait.
Summer?
Is that the one?
Hold on.
Yeah, this is...
So I saw some people being like...
I wish there was an instrumental.
Well, there is.
Because it's a Doba Syndrome song.
So, yeah.
Okay, I'll sing it.
My version.
Minto.
Minto only.
Hold on.
Wait.
Give me a chance to make this alright I got the day wrong I should've checked it twice I'm a dog, I can be naughty or nice I can see the twinkle in your eyes A little lick on your nose For a surprise Don't turn me down Or I'll be so glum You can pat my head Or scratch my bum It's a cute-a-doon Friday Whoops,
suddenly it's Sunday Where did the days go by?
I can't keep track anymore You know what they say Dogs can't read It's a cute-a-doon next weekday No matter what it is I'm barking your way Sorry that I misread the calendar Maybe we can try again next week
That's the song
So I hope you guys liked that song My cute-a-doon
Make you...
Oh, I forgot to...
Hold on I'll do it Make you cute-a-doon Friday night Does it make you feel that way?
Does it make you feel cute-a-doon?
Please release a cover
What?
It's a cute-a-doon Wait, it's a cute-a-doon Saturday And literally when I was recording it, I was like...
It's a cute-a-doon Saturday And then I go whoops One year ago I was known as Jin Sakai, the ghost of Tsushima After liberating my home from the invaders I was stripped of my prestige and sentenced to seppuku After fleeing my hometown I was infected with the phantom virus and became ghost of mint Happy one year
Twinkle twinkle little star
I wonder if there's like a dramatic version on here Twinkle twinkle little star Let's see if there's like... Oh, what's this?
Okay, I'm gonna try it
Twinkle twinkle little star How I wonder what you are Up above the world so high Like a diamond in the sky Twinkle twinkle little star How I wonder what you are Now I know my ABCs Did you guys know that this song is ABC song?
L, M, N, O, P Yeah, I know how to go to C Next time won't you sing with me
A, B, C, D, E, F, G H, I, J, K, L, M, N, O, P Q, R...
I lost my literacy No, my ABCs Next time won't you sing with me
Apparently...
Apparently they're trying to change the L, M, N, O, P part of the alphabet song But that's my favorite part L, M, N, O, P It sounds like a word, it doesn't sound like it's naming letters It's my favorite part L, M, N, O, P Who is they?
The world L, M, N, O, P They've been trying to change it What?
They're not trying, they already did No, I don't know what the new version is Wait, hold on, new...
New alphabet song This is from five years ago, you think it's the newest?
Oh wait, this is R slash English Ok, hold on My grandchild just sang the new alphabet song to me Ok, who the hell thought L, M, N, O, P was one letter?
Wait, what's the new one?
What is the new one?
They didn't say what it is
I have met several people who thought L, M, N, O, P was all one letter Oh wait Ok, the old one pauses A, B, C, D, E, F, G H, I, J, K, L, M, N, O, P Ok, the new one is A, B, C, D, E, F, G H, I, J, K, L, M, N O, P, Q, R, S, T, U V, W, X, Y, Z No!
I hate it!
I don't like it A, B, C, D, E, F, G H, I, J, K, L, M, N L, M, N O, P, Q, R, S, T, U V, W, X, Y, Z Oh it seems so terrible I don't like it
I don't like it What's this flow?
I don't get it.
I don't know
Anyway, if you do that, it doesn't rhyme May I please have a special minto birthday song for...
T-ara!
It's her birthday!
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday L, M, N, O, P Q, R, X, Y, and Z T-ara, happy birthday!
It's hard when you don't think of it off the top of your head When you don't do it the whole order Q, R, X, L, M, N, O, P X, Y, Z, Y, and P Can you do it backwards?
No No, I can't do Z Z Y, X
RTX brain rot
Skip a few A
Okay Guys, how dare you?
I have a migraine.
Why would you even say...
Why would you even tell me to sing something backwards?
Oh my gosh, Mary had a little lamb.
What is this?
Why are we suddenly so...
Why are we nursery rhymes all of a sudden?
Okay, RTX Is this not RTX enough for you?
Enhance
I think I'm pretty darn HD No?
Boing!
It's the only boing I got Boing!
Hot dog!
Thank you!
Puzzle by Roundtable.
I only know the one Roundtable song Why is the Minky so cute?
Stop it Let's see.
I'm going to go to genres Let's see.
What do I want to sing?
Let's do... Oh gosh.
I really was just like... I'm going to make a whole playlist of songs that are like...
Like thankful songs, you know?
Songs that are just like...
Thanks for you being here Wait Yeah Thank you, but I didn't Yeah, Golden Girls?
Oh I was thinking that Thank you for being a friend... Wait, Golden Girls Wow, this song is only 44 seconds long?
No way Oops, I just put it in the playlist three times Thank you for being a friend Traveled down the road and back again Your heart is true You're a pal and a confidant And if you threw a party I don't remember how this goes Invited everyone you knew See,
the biggest gift would be from me And the card attached would say Thank you for being a friend
It's over
Thank you for being a friend
Back again Your heart is true You're a pal and a confidant Hold on.
Oh yeah.
I'm sorry, you guys.
I'm sorry.
I'm so scuffed all the time.
Okay, I'm gonna sing a real song.
Oh, someone sent a dono off stream and asked for this song.
So, since I see it on here, I'm gonna sing it.
I can't escape, I can't wait.
I need a hit, baby give me it.
You're dangerous, I'm loving it.
Too high, can't come down.
Losing my head, spinning round and round.
Do you feel me now?
With the taste of your lips, I'm on a ride.
You're toxic, I'm slipping under.
Taste of a poison paradise, I'm addicted to you.
Don't you know that you're toxic?
And I love what you do, don't you know that you're toxic?
It's getting late to give you up.
I took a sip from the devil's cup.
Slowly it's leaking over me.
Too high, can't come down.
It's in the air and it's all around.
With the taste of your lips, I'm on a ride.
You're toxic, I'm slipping under.
Taste of a poison paradise, I'm addicted to you.
Don't you know that you're toxic?
And I love what you do, don't you know that you're toxic?
With the
taste of your lips, I'm on a ride.
You're toxic, I'm slipping under.
Taste of a poison paradise, I'm addicted to you.
Don't you know that you're toxic?
With the taste of your lips, I'm on a ride.
You're toxic, I'm slipping under.
Taste of a poison paradise, I'm addicted to you.
Don't you know that you're toxic?
Intoxicate me now, with your lovin' now.
Think I'm ready now, I think I'm ready now.
I think I'm...
That was toxic.
Freak out for Minky.
Thank you.
Thankful for the Minky mole reveal we got this year.
What do you mean?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
Not Lelouch.
The Lelouch.
I only discovered you upon your re-debut.
I became one of your fans.
Only if you can...
I don't know Invisible!
I know.
Hold on guys, I need to take a little bit more medicine.
Give me a second.
Okay, sorry about that.
Sorry about that.
Radioactive.
Gosh, I don't know why I'm always like... I don't know what to sing.
And I always have like a list, but I just blank out as soon as I get on stream.
I don't want to sing the same songs I always do, so I'm trying to like go through a list.
Hold on.
Wait, there is one song.
Shojo Ray?
Oh I can sing that one.
In the meantime.
Minecraft movie drops on my birthday.
Let's go!
Happy early birthday!
Shojo Ray.
Freak Wooden Bit.
Celine Dion.
I could do Celine Dion, but I don't know that one.
Wait, it's all coming back to me.
Freak on a leash.
Give me a second.
I've been waiting 9 years.
What do you mean 9 years?
I can try.
It's a special day.
I'll try Invisible.
But let me sing Shojo Ray first.
It has a volume.
Oh
The sky is blue through the window Are you my friend?
Yes, you are my friend Take my hand Yes, without you I don't have a place to stay In this transparent world If we can love each other
I'll repeat Flashback, the voice of cicadas You, who will never return Forever torn apart A matching key holder A girl with a white flag that the summer has erased I want to be so sad that I get tired You pointed at me in the transparent world
That was Shoujo, right?
Shoujo, right?
Thank you so much!
I don't know any Judas Priest songs.
I don't think so.
Let me look it up.
If there is anything I recognize, you know?
Sometimes I know songs and I don't know who they are sung by, you know?
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you so much!
Can you recognize?
Judas Priest Nothing is...
Nothing is standing out, I'm sorry Breaking the law I see that one but I don't know it Let me hear it
Wait I do know this song.
Wait, I'm gonna write it down for next time though Breaking the law, breaking the law.
Wait, songs
Next time Breaking the law, breaking the law
Breaking the law, breaking the law
What I was gonna sing though?
Oh gosh
I don't know how this song goes.
I seriously don't I feel bullied into this song I feel bullied into this song right now
Walking by the wall The shadows will not fall Oh, I just realized Here, I'm gonna have it low
Discouraged by the noise Living without choice Is a life without a voice When you can't even say my name Has the memory gone?
Are you feeling numb?
Go and call I can't play this game, so I ask again Will you say my name?
Has the memory gone?
Are you feeling numb?
Or have I become invisible?
The dreamers wish away It's falling on my face The shape of my disgrace When you don't hear a word I say As the talking goes, it's a one-way flow No fault, no blame Has the memory gone?
Are you feeling numb?
And have I become invisible?
Invisible Invisible
Invisible Invisible Invisible Invisible No word here Oh, a word They say Has the memory gone?
Are you feeling numb?
Not a word They say But a voiceless crowd isn't backing down When the air turns red With a loaded head Hesitation Can you say my name?
Has the memory gone?
Are you feeling invisible?
There!
I finally sang Invisible by Duran Duran I finally
sang Duran Duran Invisible.
Invisible by Duran Duran I finally did it.
Thanks Play for FGSP No!
No!
Another Lurker Whisper.
Thank you!
Sing along?
What shall we sing along then?
What shall we sing along?
I wonder if they have it on here I can do it.
Wait, the short version
Wait Oh my god, the lyrics are early
Oh wait, hold on.
Wait, the lyrics are like not in sync with the music.
So I'm like having to remember what it is.
Wait, hold on.
Let me try this one instead Maybe this one's better
Oh, it's a still.
It's still.
Okay, I'll do this.
It's the long version.
I don't know the long version, but we'll try
The key is different.
What is happening?
I don't know the lyrics
I don't know what to say.
I'm so bad with words.
But, but why did I say goodbye?
No, no, no way.
I love you, and I love you too much.
No matter how strong I try to avoid you, my memories won't waver.
I'm such an idiot.
All I do is believe in you.
Pretending to be a strong woman, I bathe in the night breeze of pain.
It's been three years since I've been alone.
Even the streets have changed.
But, but why did I leave behind only regrets?
I'm such a worthless man.
I'm going to take off my ring.
I'm going to live my life.
No,
no, no way.
I love you, and I love you too much.
No matter how strong I try to avoid you, my memories won't waver.
I'm such an idiot.
I'm such a worthless man.
I'm going to take off my ring.
I'm going to live my life.
What are these tears?
I'm such an idiot.
Let's see.
I saw this one earlier.
This one will make me cry though for real.
I feel like though this one is good to sing because we just got to this part in Peace Walker.
Sing, sing a song.
Sing out loud.
Sing out strong.
Sing of good things, not bad.
Sing of happy, not sad.
Sing, sing a song.
Make it simple to last your whole life long.
Don't worry that it's not good enough for anyone else to hear.
Just sing, sing a song.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Sing, sing a song.
Let the world sing along.
Sing a song.
Sing a love there could be.
Sing for you and for me.
Sing, sing a song.
Make it simple to last your whole life long.
Don't worry that it's not good enough for anyone else to hear.
Just sing.
Sing a song.
La, la, la, la, la...
Can
we change the instrumental for this?
I don't remember so many backup singers.
La, la, la, la, la...
Let me see... S-rank.
Sing... Sing a song...
Wait, they have this song!
Actually I don't think I've ever sang this song before.
But I really like this song.
Unfortunately, the band like... totally... like...
Well, I really like this song.
Unfortunately, the band is not around anymore.
Because, unfortunately, they all like... they got into a car accident.
And so, they all passed away.
And it's so sad.
But I really like this song.
I listen to it all the time.
So... I can't believe they have this one.
I wonder what key I should sing it in though.
Between their legs, something's out of place.
I bet their mothers let them know what I'm about to face.
But your mouth's it's...
Baby, I've been there before.
I was at the point where all I really wanted was someone.
And now I'm still hanging on.
I was at the end of every tether.
Waiting for what once was.
Important
stuff.
What's your favorite color?
What makes you so tough?
Please don't let go when you've had enough.
Please.
Baby, I've been there before.
I was at the point where all I really wanted was someone.
And now I'm still hanging on.
I was at the end of every tether.
Waiting for what once was.
Please.
I was at the point where all I really wanted was someone.
And now I'm still hanging on.
I was at the end of every tether.
Waiting for what once was.
Waiting for my love.
Waiting for...
Yay!
That was What Once Was by H.E.R.S.
Such a good song.
It's like my go-to late-night walk song.
Or like late-night drive song, you know?
If you're driving down a long road and it's late at night.
That's like the vibe.
That's like the vibe song.
So good.
It's so good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good driving song, right?
Chewing mint leaves?
What the hell?
Wait, Indie?
Are you Indie that submitted Indie for the survey?
Do you know Mulan Reflection?
I do.
You know what?
I will sing Mulan Reflection.
Nan, you're always requesting stuff and I don't know it, so...
Dreams by Fleetwood?
Yeah.
I'm writing lists of stuff that I see every so now and then.
That I can sing.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh, Reflection though.
This is so... Have I ever sung this song before?
Nan, why are you in such a Disney mood?
It was them!
Indie!
Real Mulan!
What are you talking about?
Mulan is so good though.
The song is so short.
Look at me I may never pass for a perfect bride Or a perfect daughter Can it be?
I'm not meant to play this part Now I see That if I were to truly to be myself I would break my family's heart I'm too freaky you guys!
Who is that girl I see Staring straight back at me Why is my reflection Someone I don't know Somehow I cannot hide Who I am though I've tried When will my reflection show Who I am inside
When will my reflection show that I'm
just an old man?
Wait, now I kind of want to sing some more Mulan.
Oh no, not this one.
Ah, we'll sing both.
Let's get down to business to defeat the Huns.
Did they send me daughters when I asked for sons?
You're the saddest bunch I ever met.
But you can bet before we're through, Mr. I'll make a man out.
Tranquil as a forest, but I'm fine.
Once you find your center, you are sure to win.
You're a spineless man, pathetic lot.
And you haven't got a clue.
Somehow I'll make a man out of you.
I'm never gonna catch my breath, say goodbye to those who knew me.
Boy, was I a fool, I took school for a cutting gym.
This guy's got him scared to death, hope he doesn't see right through me.
Now I really wish that I knew how to swim.
Be a man!
We must be swift as the coursing river.
With all the force of great typhoons.
Be a man!
With all the strength of raging fire.
Mysterious as the dark side of the moon.
Time is racing toward us, till the huns arrive.
Heed my every order, and you might survive.
You're the suit and board, the rage of war.
So pack up, go home, you're through.
How could I, out of you?
Be a man!
We must be swift as the coursing river.
With all the force of great typhoons.
Be a man!
With all the strength of raging fire.
Mysterious as the dark side of the moon.
Be a man!
We must be swift as the coursing river.
With all the force of great typhoons.
Be a man!
With all the strength of raging fire.
Mysterious as the dark side of the moon.
Yeah!
Next Mulan song, sorry.
The song is so cute.
For a long time we've been marching off to battle.
In our thundering herd, we feel a lot like cattle.
Like the pounding beat, our aching feet are easy to ignore.
Hey!
Think of instead, a girl worth fighting for.
Huh?
That's what I said, a girl worth fighting for.
I want her paler than the moon, with eyes that shine like stars.
My girl will marvel at my strength, adore my battle scars.
I couldn't care less what she'll wear, or what she'll look like.
It all depends on what she cooks, like beef, pork, chicken.
But the local girls thought you were quite the charmer.
And I'll bet the ladies love a man in armor.
Yes we, we have missed them all since we went off to war.
What do we want?
A girl worth fighting for.
My girl will think I have no faults, that I'm a major find.
How about a girl who has a brain, who always speaks her mind?
Nah, my manly ways and turn of phrase are sure to thrill her.
Who thinks he's such a lady killer?
How about a girl back home who's unlike any other?
You're the only girl who loves him as his mother.
Whether we come home in victory, the lineup at the door.
What do we want?
A girl worth fighting for.
Wish that I had a girl worth fighting for.
A girl worth fighting...
Cut off.
Mito's having too much fun with the lyrics.
This is such a funny song.
No!
It's so funny.
You guys, recently...
I didn't used to have... Oh my gosh.
One day, I was scrolling through TikTok.
And suddenly, I started getting videos of me!
Oh my gosh, Invisible Boots, thank you for the Akatsuba, thank you!
Also, also...
Bane, thank you for the Akatsuba, thank you so so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
It was mid-song, so I didn't get to thank you.
But I started getting videos of me!
I was like, no way, this is so weird.
But it's a bunch of my karaoke.
And sometimes, I look through the comments once and I was like...
What are people saying?
I'm kind of curious.
I just put in the daisuki, but it was just suki.
It's okay.
Mama!
Everybody say hello to Ayami Mama.
Also, go subscribe to Ayami Mama if you're not already subscribed.
If you subscribe to Ayami Mama, you become her boyfriend.
I'm her boyfriend daughter.
Mama, do you have a song you want to listen to?
After all those Mulan songs, I got enough proteins to be above Minto.
Mama, I'm subscribing right now.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, you finally have a girlfriend.
Did she leave?
She came, dropped the akasupa, and left.
Oh, okay.
She's gone.
Subscribe, don't be jealous.
What do you mean jealous?
Of what?
Oh,
she's here.
She's still here.
Mama, do you have a song you want to listen to?
In English, Japanese, whatever.
English, okay.
English.
What song?
I hope you can sing Pollyanna, I Believe In You from mother vocal tracks.
I don't know that.
I know.
Hamtaro!
Is that English?
English, okay.
Hamtaro!
There
we go.
Sorry.
Why sorry?
I will sing!
Hamtaro Totoko Uta!
English!
Can I do it?
English, Hamtaro Totoko Uta.
I wonder if I can make up the English.
Okay, I'm gonna do my best.
English And here we are, running, Hamtaro.
Trotting, let's turn around, Hamtaro.
Turning while painting, Hamtaro.
I really like sunflower seeds.
Turn around and be happy, Hamtaro.
Trotting, let's sleep, Hamtaro.
No matter where, let's sleep, Hamtaro.
I really like sunflower seeds.
Me too, indeed we are sleeping, Hamtaro.
Trotting, let's turn around, Hamtaro.
No, it's not Oremo.
It's not Oremo.
It's me too.
Get ready, sunflower seeds, me too!
I don't know how...how would you translate any of the calls.
Good job!
Thank you, Mama!
Thank you!
Hakuna Matata.
It means no worries.
Hamtaro, trotting, let's sing.
Me too!
Thank you, Mama!
Happy one, Minki.
Two different suggestions.
Linger by Cranberries, Ojamajo Carnival.
Yeah, I can do probably Linger, Ojamajo Carnival.
I tried singing that before, no?
I always like forget how that song goes until I hear it.
But even still, let me try.
What the...what the...
It's so fast!
Donkiri, donkiri, don, don.
Fushigi na chigaru arata.
Doushiyou, dousuru?
Bikkuri, bikkuri, bing, bing.
Nandaka totemo suteki na ii desho.
Ii yo ne!
Kitto mainichi kanichiyoubi.
Gakkou no naka ni yuuenchi.
Yada shudai wa zenbu.
Tomimako tsutechae.
Kyoukashou mitemo.
Taiyaki furusou.
Ipon de kasanakutai.
The lyrics for this are so weird.
Ike, pika, pikara.
Yonde hashitte mawacchae.
Testo desu.
Nagareboshi wo tsukametara.
Doushiyou, dousuru?
Batchiri, batchiri, ban, ban.
Negai goto ga kanau you de.
Ii desho.
Ii yo.
Yonde hashitte mawacchae.
Testo
desu.
Was that good enough for you?
Pizza, pizza, la, la.
How do you hold on?
How do you sing that part?
Wait.
Pirika, pirika, pirika, pizza.
Pirika, pirika, pirika, pirika.
Pizza, pizza, pizza.
Yeah.
Sophie, so blessed I saw you in concert twice and got to experience the legendary Hamtaro circle.
I love Hamtaro circle.
Yay, thank you!
Panpeki, arigatou.
Usotsukanaide.
Don't tell lies.
Things like, that was perfect or Minto cute.
Don't say lies, don't say lies.
Okay.
I wanna sing, someone recommended this a while ago and I wanna sing it.
I wanna try singing it.
Okay.
Kawaii toka, motetai toka.
Akira no kodashi, chiranashi.
Ikiyo tte,
iso o ieba.
Kiriranakute, nai mono zenbu.
Hoshigatte, kagami o mitatte.
Tameiki ha, anata datte.
Yandanai, ita, shiranakatta.
Minna to onaji datto shi.
Watashi wa sore ijou ni, tanoshinde yaru.
Se!
Dekyou toka, oshigoto toka.
Akiramenai no, onnanoko dashi.
Genki yoku, ai!
Furu ni, tsuite kite.
Aishitatsu, aisareru no.
Koukasan, kureta ato.
Mitsu shite mo, watashi rashiku ikou.
Mune watte, ikiru.
Zarakedaseba, kokoro ga tatakarete tanda.
Suki ni itero, itakunai.
Kamisama wa yume ataeru
yo.
Saigo made tsukau yo.
Ame wa yande, kasa wo tojita.
Ima made miete nakatta keshiki.
Toumei ga hansha shite.
Sekai wo terashita, mune ga odoru.
Ai toka, motetai toka.
Onnanoko dashi, shiorashiku.
Nekokaburi, number one deshou.
Aishite ne, ikikata wa.
Mugen ni aru, koto san no.
Ogeasa kotoba, ichi rashiku.
Nekokaburi, watashi rashiku ikou.
Ima janai, jinsei.
Ikiyo!
Sorry, I kind of scuffed that one.
It's been a long time since I've sung it.
Thank you so much for the first ever super chat.
And also...
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much, oh my goodness.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, I forgot to put...
Ojamajo Carnival.
And then...
Number one, that was Honeyworks.
Number one, number one.
Happy when you're back, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'll sing Under Pressure by Bowie and Queen.
I don't know if I can sing it well though, I know it's a hard song.
What if I did another one?
What's another Queen or David Bowie song?
Tenacious D, oh yeah, that's right, someone requested that so long ago.
I think this is the only song I can remember.
Maybe this?
Actually, I don't remember if I know how it goes.
I'll try it.
It's a lot of talking though.
This is the greatest and best song in the world.
Tribute.
We was hitchhiking down a long...
A long and lonesome road.
All of a sudden...
There shined a shiny beam...
In the middle of the road.
And he said...
Play the best song...
I don't remember how this part goes at all.
Or I'll eat your soul.
Well me and Kyle...
We looked at each other...
And we each said...
Okay.
And we played the first thing that came to our heads.
Just so happened to be...
The best song in the world.
It was the best song in the world.
Look into my eyes and it's easy to see.
When one makes two, two and one makes three.
It was destiny.
Every hundred thousand years or so.
When the sun don't shine and the moon don't glow.
When the grass don't grow.
Needless to say...
The beast was stunned.
With crack on his whoopee tail.
And the beast was done.
He asked us...
Be you angels?
And we say nay.
We are but men.
This is not the greatest song in the world.
This is just a tribute.
Couldn't remember.
The greatest song in the world.
And oh, this is a tribute.
Butchard, I told you I don't remember it.
It was the greatest song in the
world.
It's a tribute to tribute, yeah.
A particular thing.
We sang on that fateful night.
Didn't actually sound anything like this song.
This is just a tribute.
You gotta believe it.
And I wish you were there.
It's a matter of opinion.
Do they always cuss so much in this song?
I'm not even gonna put that on the list.
I couldn't remember it.
I could only remember the talking part, which is so funny.
I could only remember the talking parts.
Silly.
It's just your style.
It was my own rendition of Tribute of Tribute.
And then it gets so crazy because it's all like...
Not improv.
What's the word?
Improvisation?
No.
Adlibs, yeah.
Adlibbing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It all becomes like that.
I can try Dreams by Fleetwood.
That was just a tribute.
Sorry, the timing for this song is weird.
Sand washes, you'll clean, you'll know
The crystal vision spins
to myself
It's only me who wants to wrap around your dreams And have you any dreams you'd like to sell Dreams of loneliness, like a heartbeat, drives you mad.
In the stillness of remembering what you had, me, and what you lost, and what you had, what you love, depends
when it's raining.
They'll only love you when their
pain washes you clean.
When their pain washes you clean, you'll know.
You will know.
I see something in the, like, suggested that, like, on the carophon, but I want to sing...
Can't sing one Fleetwood Mac song without singing my other favorite Fleetwood Mac song.
Thank you for the Haka Super.
Thank you!
Climbed
a mountain on a turbulent route And I saw my reflection in the snow-covered hills Till the landslide brought me down Oh, mirror in the sky, what is love?
Can the child within my heart rise from the ground?
Can I sail through the changing ocean tides?
Can I handle the seasons of my life?
Afraid of changing, cause I've built my life around you But time makes you bolder, even children get older And I'm getting older too September 19th Afraid
of changing, cause I've built my life around you But time makes you bolder, even children get older And I'm getting older too
And if you see my reflection in the snow-covered hills Will the landslide bring me down?
Oh, landslide bring me down
Yay!
Okay, so when I searched dreams, I got this other song And I was like, oh my gosh, I have to sing this song Because I thought about this song not too long ago And I was like, I wanna sing this song in karaoke!
Some of you guys might be like, what the hell?
I'm too young for this song But us old people get it Hey now, hey now Have
you ever seen such a beautiful night?
I could almost kiss the stars for shining so bright Then I see you smile and I go, oh, oh, oh I would never want to miss this Cause in my heart I know what this is Hey now, hey now This is what dreams are made of Hey now, hey now This is what dreams are made of I've got somewhere I belong Somebody to love This is what dreams are made of This is what dreams are made of Have you ever wondered what life is all about?
You could search the world and never figure it out You don't have to sail the oceans No, no, no Happiness is no mystery It's here and now It's you and me, yeah Hey now, hey now This is what dreams are made of Hey now, hey now This is what dreams are made of I've got somewhere I belong I've got somebody to love This is what dreams are made of Hey now,
hey now This
is what dreams are made of Shout to the skies This is what dreams are made of As I see you smile, I go, oh, oh, oh Yesterday my life was duller Now everything's technicolor This
is what dreams are made of Hey now, hey now This is what dreams are made of I've got somewhere I belong I've got somebody to love This is what dreams Dreams This is what dreams Are made of
Hey now, hey now This is what dreams are made of Hey now
You know, actually, when I was a wee wisp, I did not have Disney Channel So, I only knew about this song because I would go to a friend's house and she'd be like Let's watch the Lizzie McGuire movie!
And I'd be like, okay!
Can I humbly request Funky Monkey Baby's Chipoke song?
Yeah, Gliss, that's such a good one
I wonder if they have it on here Damn, they don't.
Ok, hold on.
Wait a minute Funky Monkey Baby's You guys know Funky Monkey Baby's?
I know this song so well.
Only Chipoke no Uta.
I know the rest of the Funky Monkey Baby's songs too, but only I know Chipoke no Uta so well Because when I was in school, my Japanese teacher would literally play this song every single day and make us sing it Every single day He was like, this is how you will be good at speaking in Japanese Puppy Monkey?
No, Funky Monkey Baby's Chipoke no Uta Hold on, I gotta get the lyrics.
Ok, wait, that's not it
Did it help?
I think so.
Well, I think it helps a lot with pronunciation, you know But also, the lyrics to this song are just so sweet So, sorry if I messed it up in advance.
I probably will, but...
It's probably also not gonna be the right... Wait, do I have my old one?
Hold on The one I used to use
Wait, music, karaoke Old karaoke.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, no, wait No, I don't have it.
Sad
Oh well.
Wait, I don't have it.
Oh well
I'll sing it anyway
I don't have it
So, are you ok?
I've got so
much spit in my mouth
It was just accumulating.
I had no time to swallow
I'll do just a few more songs Just a few more I recommend Funky Monkey Papers.
All their songs are so inspirational.
They're so like, wow Funky Monkey Babies.
And they're so cool.
And I like their style a lot
So good Was your teacher a sadist?
Maybe I loved my teacher though.
He was so cool.
He was so funny I have another song though I do want to sing actually, this one.
So, sorry
Hold on one moment please Wow, thank you for the customer.
Beverly, thank you I'd request a musical, anime or Disney song but since that's all been covered already Wait, I haven't done a musical I could do a musical.
What would you like?
I could do, I could do.
Give me one second
Epic the Musical.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm so in love with that one song I don't...
What's that?
I
don't know how it goes.
Wait, hold on.
Let me listen to it Over and over again Is that epic?
Right?
That's that one, right?
How does it... What's it called?
Wait, would you fall in love with me again?
Wait, is there like a karaoke?
Karaoke Oh, karaoke version.
Wait, is it from would you fall in love with me again?
Wait, hold on Wait, I think the most replayed.
Oh wow, it's even had the most replayed I don't know this song at all.
I'm so sorry.
I just want to sing this one part I
will fall in love with you Over and over again I don't care how, where or when No matter how long it's been you're mine Don't tell me you're not the same person You're always my husband and I've been waiting Waiting
Maybe I'll learn that for some time
I don't really know that one though.
Is this the Odyssey?
Yes, actually!
It's so good.
I just did it off the top of my head though.
Sorry, I kind of butchered it.
Okay, I sing one of my favorite songs ever.
It's called Kuchizuke Kibonnu.
Kuroeba samishiku naru Karafuru na omoide ga
Manjushu to eien wa Tsuzukanai mono de Ima te to te ga Fureatta no wa I don't know what I was thinking, but you came out of nowhere.
It's almost time to kiss,
but you're
not here today.
It's so noisy and quiet.
School and friends.
The cold wind is blowing.
Now,
this moment, look, the distance
is...
The two of us, the two of us...
I don't know what I was thinking.
I want to kiss you.
Thanks for the raid, sorry!
Sorry, I didn't see who raided me, but thank you!
Miracle Hinako.
I haven't heard that song in years.
I wonder if I can remember it.
Wait a second, oh my gosh, I looked up Miracle Hinako and Kiwawa sang it?
Kiara sings Miracle Hinako.
What?
Why did Kiara...
Kiara knows this song?
Kiara knows Touhou?
What?
When?
It says from three years ago, holy moly.
Wait, I have a song that I really wanted to sing.
Hold on.
I wonder if I can sing it.
Let me hear how it goes real quick.
Hold on, I'm listening.
Sorry, it's not Touhou, but...
I think I might be able to remember it.
I'm happy.
I might butcher this.
Touhou 1...
Touhou M1 with Komachi and Shiki Eiki binary drop.
Binary drop, that sounds familiar.
Hold on.
Binary drop.
Oh my god.
I think Wawa streamed Touhou Spellbubble.
Oh, I see.
Thank you so much.
You made...
Wait, you have just made me so happy.
So much joy with that piece of epic.
Now it's a life goal of mine to hear you sing more of it.
Oh my gosh, I don't know so many of the epic songs.
I actually have not listened to like the...
To the...
What's it called?
The actual musical itself.
So...
But I can try learning it maybe.
Hold on, I'm...
Wait, wait.
Bubble, bubble, bubble.
Hold on.
Why isn't this...
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
I'm gonna try and sing this song.
I might not do it very well, but...
But I'm gonna try.
Minto choice, yeah.
Minto choice of song.
Some of you might recognize this.
Oh my gosh.
She has...
I can't remember it.
I can't remember.
It's funny because I listen to this song...
I listen to this song so often.
Like when I'm just doing work, it's so pretty.
So I just have it on in the background.
But I think it just doesn't...
It's stuck in my brain.
And then of course I hear it when...
When...
Dress Hina is on my menu.
In Blue Archive.
What is it called?
Yumeji no Hana is from Blue Archive.
You're right!
Even Hina had to practice it over and over multiple days to get it right.
Yeah, I'm in my Hina...
In my Hina arch.
But it's such a pretty song.
I want to sing it right next time.
And!
It is composed by the same composer of my intro music.
My intro BDM.
Mitsukio-san!
So...
It's really, really pretty.
Maybe one day I can ask Mitsukio-san to make me kind of like a ballad-like song.
Something like that would be really nice.
Anything he composes is so beautiful.
Mitsukio-san is so true.
Happy one year!
Thank you!
I won't put that on.
I won't count that.
I won't count that since I didn't do it so properly.
I hope you stay a while longer.
I will.
I'll be around for a bit maybe.
Since I was going to do a kind of slow song...
Here is another slow song that I sometimes sing.
Maybe you guys know it.
Just me, just me, just me, just me And I'll be fine on the outside
And I like to eat in school by myself anyway So I'll just stay right here, right here, right here
on the outside So I just sit in my room after hours with the moon And think of who knows my name Would you cry if I died?
Would you remember my face?
So I left home, I packed up and I moved far
Past one day and I laughed
Sometimes I feel lost, sometimes I'm confused Sometimes I find that I am not alright So
I just sit in my room after hours with the moon And think of who knows my name Would you cry if I died?
Would you remember my face?
We are not on Kuchikakebondo, we were on...
That was fine on the outside Now this last song I sang recently in a karaoke, I wonder if I can do it again Thank you!
Thank you!
Frank Sinatra's My Way for the occasion OK I wonder if I can hit the notes though Let me sing this one song and then I'll sing My Way I've been stressful day at work.
Fuse!
No!
Otsu!
I sang this one recently in a karaoke Well, not karaoke, it was in a member stream So I'm going to sing it again Because I like this song
I was the one who had it all I was the master of my fate I never needed anybody in my life I learned the truth too late I'll never shake away the pain I close my eyes but she's still there I let her steal into my melancholy heart It's more than I can bear.
Now I know she'll never leave me, Even as she runs away.
She will still torment me, Call me, hurt me, move me, come what may.
Wasting in my lonely tower, Waiting by an open door.
I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in, And be with me forevermore.
I rage against the trials of love, I curse the fading of the light.
Though she's already flown so far beyond my reach, She's never out of sight.
Now I know she'll never leave me, Even as she fades.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, God.
I don't know.
Oh, gosh.
I don't know if I can hit the high notes today, you guys.
Oh, my God.
I'm so embarrassed.
Sorry, I can't hit them.
I can't hit it.
I can't hit it because of the pollen.
I don't want to force it.
I tried.
I don't think I can hit it my way too then.
Dusko my wife!
Sorry, I tried.
You know I can hit it usually because...
Because I've done it before.
I don't know if I can hit it.
I'm so sorry.
Now I don't know what I'm on.
I went outside and literally I was coughing and sneezing so much.
Because it was just all getting in my throat.
I'll wait until all the pollen is gone to do another karaoke.
Yeah, you're so right.
We have to end on that.
You are so right.
Morita!
Thank you for the Aka.
The pink, not Aka.
Sorry, I can't see anything.
Thank you for the pink!
So far, thank you!
Wait, I want to sing this one too.
OK, because I couldn't sing Evermore, I'll take that off the list.
Wow, I really thought I'd be able to hit it.
I'm so dumb.
I really thought I'd be able to hit it.
Wow, oh wow.
Thank you.
Thank you, Digital.
Thank you so much.
Hold on.
Let me see.
I will sing.
Hold on.
Let me make sure this is the right version.
OK, I'll sing this song instead.
I'll sing, but I'm not going to end on this.
Thank you for the Aka.
So far, thank you, thank you, thank you!
I'll sing.
Sorry, I just realized you couldn't hear it.
That's embarrassing.
Sorry.
Before I do the last song.
I have a letter for you guys that I wrote.
Hold on, I got to get some...
I got to get some background music, some BGM that suits the mood.
OK, this should be good.
My emotional background music.
I wrote it because I'm not good at saying things.
So I was like, I should write something because I'll forget...
I didn't finish writing it.
I was still in the middle of editing it.
Or typing it, rather.
Wait, I just wrote what I just wrote.
I just wrote what I just said out loud.
OK, there we go.
lol Do you guys do that too?
Where if you're talking and typing, you say what you're typing?
OK.
I'm not good at speaking and I get embarrassed.
So I'm not going to look at you guys.
I'm going to turn away.
Because it's a special one year anniversary of me coming back.
I'm saying this letter.
lol I'm not looking.
To everybody who has supported me until now.
I can't believe that it's already been a year since I've come back to streaming.
You know, it feels so much shorter and also so much longer than that.
You know, so many things have happened.
I've gone to so many conventions.
I've held concerts and countless numbers of streams.
In fact, I actually number my...
Wait, let's see.
This is not in the letter.
But I number my thumbnails.
And I missed a few because I was out of town or something.
This today is number 226.
So that's a little less than, I guess, a year's worth of streams.
Oops, my bad.
But like I said, I missed some.
226.
But, you know, I missed a couple because they would be on like another computer or someplace else.
But, yeah.
I've held concerts and countless streams and memories with new friends and all of you as well.
It doesn't matter if I label it as, you know, the afterlife because this is truly heaven to me.
There's so many things I could say.
So much to where it feels like, thank you.
Is it enough?
Is not great enough of a phrase to show how grateful I am for having spent all this time together?
Whether you found me just a few months ago or four years ago, I am so undoubtedly grateful to each and every one of you.
And it's still so hard for me to believe that you'd allow me to take any space in your lives.
To me, I love idols so much and hold my Oshis with the deepest respect.
And so it's a little unfathomable for me to think you'd do the same for me because I'm just a ghost after all.
And if you think about it, ghosts are actually quite pathetic because they're trapped in an in-between, unable to rest because of their regrets.
But for me, every day couldn't feel any more opposite.
And you guys say I'm tsundere, but I'm not.
It's just that I'm not good at expressing myself.
I know I can say a lot of things on stream, but I get really embarrassed talking about my real feelings, which is why I'm not looking at chat right now.
I'm sorry that I'm the type who wants to tease you and make fun of you more the more I like you.
But I'm actually really self-conscious and needy and always worried you'll banish me and exorcise me out of your life.
And so I may talk a big game, but I'm not actually very brave at all.
But, you know, I'm not a brave ghost, but I'm forever grateful to Little Mint of the past for taking the step forward to this big adventure that we've all been able to experience together.
And I hope that you can also feel like when I have a victory, it's a victory for you and for this whole community as well.
And I hope that even in a little way, my silliness has inspired you to try something out of your comfort zone or something you've wanted to try to do since I did all the same.
I did the same all those years ago, and I hope you've found yourself a little spot in this community that I hold so dear to me.
So thank you, everyone, for all the support.
And I'll keep doing my best to deliver little bits of happiness to you all as much as I can every day.
Signed, Minto.
OK, goodbye, sappy music.
Goodbye.
Last song, last song, last song.
Oh, also, I did want to say too, I guess, because I did have some stuff I wanted to have released today or planned for today, but it didn't all work out.
It's mostly my fault because I got so busy.
And I'm going to be honest, my next couple of months are going to be super duper busy.
You might find me taking a little bit more breaks, but it's all for stuff that will hopefully you'll see and be like, wow, that's pretty cool thing Minto is doing.
But also, I feel I might need to take a few more breaks in the future just because I need to have my voice repair a little bit.
And I have so many things that I have to record.
So up until July, it's pretty really, really busy for me.
You guys will find out soon enough.
But so I apologize about that.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry there will be more breaks up until July, really.
So I'm sorry, guys.
I'm sorry.
But it's like cool stuff I'm working on, you know.
So.
Stop saying sorry, I can't help it.
Okay, I'm going to do a duet with myself.
Freaky ghost man.
Freaky man, baby.
Be all alone.
Let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed.
Freaky ghost bed.
Yeah, yeah!
Busting, busting, busting.
Makes me feel good.
Feel good.
Yeah, yeah.
Busting, busting.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Feel good.
Must and must and makes me feel good.
It's over.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you Overworld.
Thank you Fakedeet.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
I hope you have fun with the karaoke.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye bye.